sanju bhagat is a farmer from nagpur
india and his life was pretty normal
until his 20s when he started to develop
a small bulge in his stomach
as the years went on the bulge grew
larger and people from his village would
tease him that he looked like he was
pregnant
they didn't know how close to the truth
they were
[Music]
sanju's childhood was normal he had no
medical issues at least none that he was
aware of he never showed signs of a
tumor or any pain now sanji was poor and
from an early teenager he had to work to
feed his family and he worked on farms
which is pretty physically demanding in
his 20s he noticed that his stomach was
growing but it wasn't fat the rest of
his body was actually thin now medical
care was expensive and says it wasn't
causing him any pain he just kept living
his life but as he got into his 30s his
large belly made work more difficult he
started getting back pains and was
having trouble breathing so in 1999 at
the age of 36 sanju collapsed when he
couldn't catch his breath he was rushed
by an ambulance to a hospital in mumbai
dr ajay meadow was on duty that day and
immediately thought this was a tumor and
he said the tumor was so large that it
was pressing on sanju's diaphragm
disrupting his ability to breathe now
the doctors knew they had to remove the
tumor as quickly as possible to save
sanju's life now as they prepared for
surgery the medical staff noticed
something strange the tumor was actually
feeding on the contents of sanji's
stomach and when dr meta made the
incision gallons of fluid came out
he was then horrified to find this
wasn't a tumor at all
when dr metta tried to extract a large
tumor from sanji's stomach he said to my
surprise and horror i could shake hands
with somebody inside dr mehta realized
this wasn't a tumor at all it was
actually the mutated body of sanju's
twin brother the deformed fetus had arms
and legs bones hair a jaw teeth and
somehow sanju had carried the fetus
inside his body since birth and for 36
years it continued to live and grow now
this medical condition is very rare it's
called fetus infidu and it's defined as
the presence of one twin inside the body
of another which survives like a
parasite the fetus forms a cord like an
umbilical cord that leeches blood and
nutrients from its host now only 200
cases of fetus infetu have ever been
reported the earliest case occurred in
the early 19th century it was discovered
by johann meckel a german anatomist now
in that case a woman who insisted she
wasn't pregnant gave birth to a deformed
fetus and doctors soon learned that
she'd actually carried her twin her
entire life now fetus infeto happens
early in embryo development when it's
just a ball of cells called a blastocyst
now it's rare but sometimes a blastocyst
divides and grows twin fetuses but in
this rare case they divide unevenly and
one fetus gets stuck inside the other
now most of the time the condition is
fatal to both twins which causes a
miscarriage but on some very rare
occasions one or both survive delivery
the condition usually goes unnoticed
until the parasitic twin grows so large
it actually causes discomfort in the
host as was the case with sanju bhagat
medical reports show that the
fingernails of the fetus were quite long
indicating it had been alive for a long
time after sanji was born and after
sanji recovered from the surgery he went
from 200 pounds to 88 pounds
even though the case was considered by
doctors to be a medical miracle sanju
said his condition was a source of
misery and shame sanju didn't make a
full recovery he's in good health and
now leads a normal life all his life
people had teased him about being
pregnant they didn't realize how right
they were
thanks for hanging out my name is aj
this is the y files if you had fun or
learned anything do me a favor like
comment subscribe and share and until
next time be safe be kind know that you
are appreciated
[Applause]
[Music]
you